let's take a look at the elitism
so you start
here's one of the paragraphs that says
uh lawrence led me through a sunken den
we're gonna go to
this is what it says lawrence led me
through a sunken den
to a large outdoor dining area that was
screened in southern style
as she uncorked a bottle of white wine
she warned me that she was in a mood not
a bad mood exactly but a consistently
emotional one
brought on by the supreme court decision
overturning roe v wade a few days
earlier you already are like jed i'm not
gonna have the stomach for it listen
take a little pepto don't take pepto
actually take a little um
what is it seltzer water you know i
don't like that big pharma stuff and
just chill for a second you need to hear
it it goes on and on and she talks about
how
she had great disappointment in the 2016
election this was one of my favorite
lines
the 2016 election had torn open a rift
in her family so it gets into how she
doesn't see eye to eye with her parents
she comes from a conservative family in
kentucky repairing it was an ongoing
process particularly since having a baby
she had been trying to heal
she even discussed with her therapist
the recurring nightmares she has about
tucker carlson
i mean could you just girlfriend i
tweeted girlfriend get a backbone
honestly rachel maddow does not keep me
up at night at all if tucker carlson's
keeping you up at night you got no
problems that's how you know you've got
no problems because you know what the
rest of the country is up at night
thinking about how to pay gas bills how
to pay or how to fill up their car
how am i going to put food on the table
and do this how am i going to work and
afford child care she's up thinking
about tucker
come on
again tone deaf
so she goes on and on and on and she
says i just worked so hard in the last
five years to forgive my dad and my
family and to try to understand it's
different the information they're
getting is different their life is
different she cannot wrap her head
around how her family sees the world
differently and that's another sign of
an elitist by the way because they
cannot
imagine
that you have a different viewpoint it's
like how can this because she's in a
bubble she's in a hollywood bubble
she's in a california she's in a
southern california bubble that's inside
of a hollywood bubble so she's just all
bubbled up you know
okay
then she gets into roe v wade and she
talks about trump you knew was coming
she says she had not now this is the
author of the article she had not been
entirely in hillary clinton's corner
which is interesting they put that in
because even the elitists can't stand
hillary clinton that was a little dig
that was a little dick you know it even
the left-wing elitist can't stand
hillary's spacing woman inspires just
nobody likes her
anyway but still found it incredibly
upsetting that the country elected
donald trump this is a quote it breaks
my heart because america had the choice
between a woman and a dangerous
dangerous drive mayonnaise
and they were like well we can't have a
woman let's go with the jar of
mayonnaise
so i i read this to you this part
because there are still people out there
who believe that hillary clinton didn't
win the election because she was a woman
they will not acknowledge that well
maybe hillary clinton didn't win the
election because she was a terrible
candidate
because she skipped a whole bunch of
states because she's an elitist because
she was a liar she had lied to the whole
email scandal and everybody knew she
lied and she signed papers that she lied
in she should be in jail by the way for
that stuff you know it
um and she was a fraud and maybe they
were tired of the clinton dynasty and
they didn't want that anymore no no no
no no it's because everyone's a
misogynist
they
the talking points leave certain cable
news outlets or the new york times and
they just like
you know i'm gonna do the gulp
you know it
okay
she realized she was a liberal she grew
up in a republican family do you know
how she realized she was a liberal this
is not a joke
one night when she was 16 she was
watching 30 rock don't we all discover
our political ideology and identity by
watching television everything i know
about politics i owe to tina fey there
you go absolutely for me it was south
park as a 16 year old right right
and liz lemon said something
i know southpark you know and liz lemon
said something along the lines of i'm
not a crazy liberal i just think people
should drive hybrid cars
it made sense it seemed rational the
author says i mean as if liberalism
could be summed up by the desire not you
know statism
not big government control of your life
not high taxes
no none of that just hybrid cars yeah
cool
okay
then
it goes on to her republican had always
meant why should my taxes pay for your
haughty lifestyle
now she saw holes in this logic
nobody likes to see their paycheck go
away but it made sense to me yeah
for the greater good
i guess it makes sense the greater good
you hear that all the time right the
greater good
remember that during covid you had to
get the vaccine even if your doctor told
you it was bad for you because it was
for the greater good even though the
vaccine didn't prevent transmission it's
nonsense the greater good is a communist
talking point by the way
that's what communist dictators said do
it for the greater good that means
sacrifice your individual liberty
your individual freedom and what's best
for you and your family for the greater
good and then you know what big thumb
this is the little thumb of government
it's way bigger than this i have a small
thumb what can i say goes right down on
you and you're suppressed next thing you
know you have no freedom oh but it was
for the greater good and then you
swallow that too right because they turn
you into a puppet
people are so predictable to nausea
except
for of course the top of the top there's
no remember even in communists you know
countries dictatorships whatever there's
always an elite
they're protected she'd be in the elite
hollywood hollywood star she's protected
she goes on to talk about abortion and
she says that she got pregnant in her
early 20s
and she intended to get an abortion she
didn't have the abortion because she had
a miscarriage okay so she goes on to
alpine and she says i remember a million
times thinking about it while i was
pregnant thinking about the things that
were happening to my body and i had a
great pregnancy i had a very fortunate
pregnancy this is when she actually
became pregnant
the second time but every single second
of my life was different and it would
occur to me sometimes what if i was
forced to do this so let me let me turn
that little light bulb in her head on
for a second
there it's you're not forced
you're not forced
here's a really great idea if you don't
want i know this is going to say i'm a
neanderthal but if you don't want to
risk having a baby don't have sex
everyone's like jed okay here's another
option
use several forms of protection do
something
or here's a better idea i have it
get involved in a relationship with
someone that you love and that you trust
and that you want to be intimate with
knowing full well that a baby could come
out of that and ahead of time decide
that if that happens you're gonna take
care of that baby it's a decision you
make and then go have your fun no no no
no no
that's not what they want they don't
want personal responsibility injected
into any equation no no
that's a bad thing that makes you
accountable for your actions and
liberals can't have that it's
distressing
okay
um then she gets into guns
and she says how on earth can anyone
have children and not want to restrict
access to guns she wanted to know
i'm raising a little boy so am i jen so
am i
i'm raising a little boy who's going to
go to school one day guns are the number
one cause of death for children in the
united states and people are still
voting for politicians who receive money
from the nra it blows my mind i mean if
sandy hook didn't change anything we as
a nation just went okay we're allowing
our children to lay down their lives for
our right to a second amendment that was
written over 200 years ago oh the second
amendment was written 200 oh
forget it then
let's just tear that constitution up
let's just rip it up for jennifer here
we go there we go sorry jessie kelly
that was your interview questions
and this is the living the constitution
needs to be living breathing right of
course because you know why
we've covered it you know why nothing is
factual to these people there's all
there's no facts
right what biology meant yesterday can't
mean that today we're just growing we're
evolving we're all subjective clouds you
know how this works
and nothing that built the country just
a document
that built the country oh no that has to
cease to exist it's old it's antiquated
it doesn't fit who we are today let's
just get rid of it if you like the short
clip you can catch another one here or
you can catch the full episode right
here
[Music]